Something awful has happened, maybe to you, maybe to someone you care about. It might have been a car accident, a mugging, something distressing at work, or witnessing something traumatic in everyday life. Whatever it was you or someone you care about has been left feeling a bit out of sorts. Maybe jumpy, wired, tearful or exhausted. Or maybe you or they are not feeling much of anything yet and you are left wondering what's normal after something like this.
发生了一些可怕的事情，也许是发生在你身上，也许是发生在你关心的人身上。这可能是一场车祸、一次抢劫、工作中令人苦恼的事情，或者是在日常生活中目睹了创伤性事件。无论是什么，你或你关心的人都感到有些不对劲。也许会感到焦虑、紧张、想哭或精疲力竭。或者，你或他们可能还没有什么特别的感觉，你还在纳闷在经历这样的事情后，什么是正常的。
I am Dr Marianne Trent, a clinical psychologist, and in this episode we are going to be exploring how people often respond to trauma, what kind of reactions are common, what tends to help, and how to tell when someone might benefit from additional support. My hope is that by the end of this episode you will feel more confident in knowing what's normal, what's to be expected and what might signal that someone needs a little more help. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along. I'm Dr. Marianne and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I'm also a specialist in trauma. And often people will get in contact with me to say,
我是临床心理学家玛丽安·特伦特博士，在这一集中，我们将探讨人们通常如何应对创伤，哪些反应是常见的，什么往往会有所帮助，以及如何判断一个人是否需要额外的支持。我希望在这一集结束时，你能更有信心地了解什么是正常的，什么是可以预期的，以及什么可能预示着某人需要更多的帮助。希望你觉得这很有用。你好，欢迎收听。我是玛丽安博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我也是创伤方面的专家。人们经常联系我说，
this has happened, what do I do? This episode is all about that. You might be working with people in post-traumatic situations, or you might be someone that just loves or cares about or has experienced something really scary yourself. I really hope you find this content helpful. If you are finding the content helpful I'd be so grateful if you drop me
发生了这样的事，我该怎么办？这一集就是关于这个主题的。你可能正在与处于创伤后情况的人一起工作，或者你可能是一个爱着、关心着某人，或者自己经历了一些非常可怕的事情的人。我真心希望你觉得这些内容有帮助。如果你觉得这些内容有帮助，如果你能给我
a like and a comment and even a subscribe if you're watching on YouTube. So firstly, when something big or scary happens it's really normal because we're human that we are going to respond to that. What we might think of as emotional aftershocks might happen immediately after the event or might be a bit delayed too. It can be helpful to group these responses into one of four categories and they are physical, emotional, behavioral and cognitive. And what we know is that sometimes people might initially feel fine or say that they're fine But that doesn't always mean that that's going to stay that way And of course what we know about people is they may not always tell you the truth
点个赞、留个言，甚至如果你在YouTube上观看的话订阅一下，我会非常感激。首先，当重大或可怕的事情发生时，作为人类，我们会有所反应是非常正常的。我们所认为的情绪余震可能在事件发生后立即出现，也可能会有所延迟。将这些反应归为四类是有帮助的，它们分别是：生理、情绪、行为和认知。我们所知道的是，有时人们最初可能感觉很好，或者说他们很好，但这并不意味着情况会一直这样。当然，我们对人的了解是，他们并不总是会告诉你真相。
So being able to tune into the person and looking out for these signs and symptoms Might be really useful in helping you to work out whether you or someone you care about really is fine. Let's take a look at the physical symptoms that someone might experience from stress related or traumatic events. So they are fatigue, nausea, muscle tremors, twitches, chest pains, difficulty or changes in breathing, increased blood pressure, rapid heart rate, thirst, headaches, visual difficulties or changes, vomiting, grinding teeth, weakness, dizziness, profuse sweating, chills, shock, fainting. A few of those are flagged for if you experience them or someone you care about experiences them that medical advice should be sought. And those were the ones like chest pains, difficulty or
因此，能够关注当事人并留意这些迹象和症状，对于帮助你判断你或你关心的人是否真的“很好”可能非常有用。让我们来看看一个人在压力相关或创伤性事件中可能经历的生理症状。它们包括：疲劳、恶心、肌肉震颤、抽搐、胸痛、呼吸困难或变化、血压升高、心率加快、口渴、头痛、视觉困难或变化、呕吐、磨牙、虚弱、头晕、大量出汗、发冷、休克、昏厥。其中一些症状如果出现，或者你关心的人出现这些症状，应寻求医疗建议。这些症状包括胸痛、呼吸困难或
changes in breathing, a rapid heart rate, headaches, visual difficulties or changes, shock and fainting. The second of our groups of symptoms falls into the thoughts category. And that might include things like blaming someone, confusion, poor attention, poor decisions, heightened or lowered alertness, poor concentration, memory problems, difficulty identifying familiar things or people, poor problem solving, loss of person, place or time orientation, disturbed thinking and nightmares.
呼吸变化、心率加快、头痛、视觉困难或变化、休克和昏厥。我们的第二类症状属于思维范畴。这可能包括责怪他人、困惑、注意力不集中、决策能力差、警觉性过高或过低、专注力差、记忆问题、难以识别熟悉的事物或人、解决问题能力差、对人、地点或时间失去定向感、思维紊乱和噩梦。
The third of our symptoms are grouped in the emotional category and they might include anxiety, guilt, grief, denial, severe panic which can be rarer, fear, uncertainty, loss of emotional control, depression or low mood, feeling overwhelmed, intense anger, irritability, being extra hypervigilant and flashbacks. The fourth and final group of our symptoms are in the behaviour category and they might include changes in level of physical activity, change in speech style or pattern, withdrawal, emotional outbursts, suspiciousness, poor communication, increased alcohol intake, increased drug or medication consumption, inability to
第三类症状属于情绪范畴，可能包括焦虑、内疚、悲伤、否认、严重的恐慌（这比较罕见）、恐惧、不确定感、失去情绪控制、抑郁或情绪低落、感到不知所措、强烈的愤怒、易怒、过度警觉和闪回。第四类也是最后一类症状属于行为范畴，可能包括身体活动水平的变化、言语风格或模式的改变、退缩、情绪爆发、多疑、沟通能力差、酒精摄入增加、药物或处方药消耗增加、无法
rest, antisocial acts, an intensified startle reflex, pacing around, erratic or jerky movements, agitation and apprehension. Now of course many of those signs and symptoms kind of do indicate what it is to be human but you will know what is normal for you or what is normal for the person that you are concerned about and so it's really tuning in to what changes have happened from what we would call a person's normal baseline. So if somebody already consumes alcohol every day and they continue at the same pace that's not necessarily an indication that they might be struggling. Whereas if they very rarely drink or they usually tea total and after this traumatic or stressful event they begin to consume alcohol on a
休息、反社会行为、惊跳反射增强、来回踱步、动作古怪或抽动、烦躁和忧虑。当然，许多这些迹象和症状在某种程度上确实表明了什么是人性，但你会知道什么是对你正常的，或者什么是对你所关心的人正常的，所以关键在于关注一个人从所谓的“正常基准线”发生了什么变化。因此，如果某人本来每天都喝酒，并且他们保持同样的频率，这并不一定表明他们可能正在挣扎。然而，如果他们很少喝酒，或者通常滴酒不沾，而在这次创伤性或压力事件后，他们开始
daily basis or that you notice that they seem to suddenly start appearing drunk, that may of course indicate there's been a change. Similarly if somebody usually struggles with migraines and they then get migraines at the normal interval for them, it doesn't necessarily mean that they're experiencing the traumatic event. I've put together an entirely fictional case study which might give us a better idea about what kinds of things we might experience and notice and how this plays out in reality. As I said, this is entirely a fictional account and not based on anyone that I know or have worked with. Jordan is a 32 year old marketing manager and they were involved in a multi car collision on a motorway.
每天喝酒，或者你注意到他们似乎突然开始表现出醉酒的样子，那当然可能表明发生了变化。同样，如果某人通常受偏头痛困扰，而他们随后在正常的间隔期内出现偏头痛，这并不一定意味着他们正在经历创伤性事件。我整理了一个完全虚构的案例研究，这可能让我们更好地了解我们可能会经历和注意到什么，以及这在现实中是如何表现的。正如我所说，这是一个完全虚构的叙述，并不基于我认识或共事过的任何人。乔丹是一位32岁的营销经理，他们卷入了一起高速公路上的多车连环相撞事故。
Although they weren't physically injured they witnessed someone being taken away in an ambulance and were badly shaken by the experience. In the days following the incident Jordan noticed themselves being unusually tearful, often crying without a clear reason, especially when recalling parts of the event. Normally quite sociable, they started avoiding phone calls and skipping social plans, preferring to stay at home alone. Jordan also found it difficult to fall asleep and was waking up several times during the night, sometimes feeling panicked or sweaty. Loud noises, especially car horns or sirens,
虽然他们没有身体受伤，但他们目睹了有人被救护车带走，并被这次经历吓坏了。在事件发生后的几天里，乔丹注意到自己异常爱哭，经常无缘无故地哭泣，尤其是在回忆事件片段时。他们平时很善于交际，但开始回避电话并推掉社交计划，宁愿独自待在家里。乔丹还发现很难入睡，晚上会醒来好几次，有时感到恐慌或出汗。巨大的噪音，尤其是汽车喇叭声或警笛声，
started making them jumpy and tense, and they began scanning the road obsessively when driving again. To try and cope with the tension and the poor sleep, Jordan started drinking more alcohol in the evenings than usual, telling themselves it was just to take the edge off. In our case study, we are looking a little further ahead with Jordan, whereas of course you might find that the event has happened right now, but these are useful things to look out for. So for example, when Jordan went back to work, they were functioning relatively okay, but
开始让他们变得神经质和紧张，他们再次开车时开始强迫性地扫描路面。为了应对紧张和睡眠质量差的问题，乔丹开始在晚上比平时喝更多的酒，告诉自己这只是为了缓解压力。在我们的案例研究中，我们对乔丹的情况看得更远了一些，当然你可能会发现事件刚刚发生，但这些都是值得注意的事情。例如，当乔丹回到工作岗位时，他们的工作功能相对正常，但
found that they felt distracted and exhausted and had started to wonder whether what they were feeling was normal and whether they should seek help. So whilst this is not based on an individual known to me these are a really common collection of signs and symptoms post-trauma. We'll often see people who perhaps have experienced the birth of a child or in birthing their own child will experience some post-trauma. It is so so common but it's often not flagged as being a trauma response. So these are really important signs and symptoms to look out for. So what are the helpful
发现自己感到分心和精疲力竭，并开始怀疑自己的感受是否正常，以及是否应该寻求帮助。所以，虽然这不是基于我认识的某个人，但这些是创伤后非常常见的迹象和症状集合。我们经常看到那些可能经历了孩子出生，或者在生下自己的孩子时经历了一些创伤的人。这非常非常普遍，但通常不会被标记为创伤反应。所以这些是非常重要的迹象和症状，需要留意。那么，在创伤事件后，
things to be able to do after a traumatic event? Firstly spending time with people that you feel and trust or being around trusted people. That might be family, it might be friends, it might be loved ones. There can also be some value in spending time with people who are also involved in that experience to help to debrief it a bit too. Where possible, maintaining your usual routines can actually be protective of your mental health and functioning.
能够做些什么是有帮助的呢？首先是与你感到信任的人共度时光，或者与值得信赖的人在一起。这可能是家人、朋友或爱人。与同样参与过该经历的人共度时光，帮助进行一些复盘，也可能是有价值的。在可能的情况下，保持你通常的日常作息实际上可以保护你的心理健康和功能。
That it might involve when you get up, when you go to bed, when you rest, when you exercise, when you eat. If you don't usually exercise, gentle movement or being outside or taking part in physical activity can also be really really important. Of course if you've been physically injured as a result of the traumatic incident that might be problematic and so if you have please do get yourself signed off by your medical practitioner before attempting any physical activity. So limiting alcohol and certainly not drinking more than you usually would is absolutely advised as well as talking to someone either a
这可能涉及你起床的时间、睡觉的时间、休息的时间、锻炼的时间、吃饭的时间。如果你平时不锻炼，轻柔的运动、待在户外或参加体育活动也可能非常非常重要。当然，如果你因为创伤性事件而身体受伤，那可能会有问题，所以如果你受伤了，请务必在尝试任何体育活动之前先获得医生的许可。因此，限制饮酒，当然不要喝得比平时多，是绝对建议的，同时与某人交谈，无论是
mental health professional or a friend or family about your experiences can be so protective of mental health. Only taking medication as prescribed and not being swayed by any unprescribed or recreational drugs can be so important. If you find that your symptoms are not being managed by what you're already prescribed, please do contact your prescribing clinician as soon as possible. Knowing that the way that our brains work is that we will process things. It might feel like we're feeling really intense reactions right now, but knowing that these are likely to pass and we won't always feel this way can be so powerful too.
心理健康专业人士，还是朋友或家人，谈论你的经历，对保护心理健康非常有帮助。只按处方服用药物，不被任何非处方药或娱乐性药物所左右，这一点非常重要。如果你发现你的症状无法通过你已经服用的药物来控制，请尽快联系你的处方医生。要知道，我们大脑的工作方式是会处理事情的。现在感觉反应非常强烈，但要知道这些很可能会过去，我们不会一直这样，这也会非常有力量。
Let's talk about some other things that I recommend to people post-trauma which can be really helpful. Firstly is our before, during and after approach. This is where we split the chunks of time around the incident into three. So the before section would be maybe from when you first woke up that day and everything was normal, all the things you did or they did which ran up until the time when just before you noticed something was different. So for example in the case of Jordan they got up that day, got showered, got breakfasted, dropped children off at school, then got in the car and listened to the radio and was driving.
让我们谈谈我向创伤后的人推荐的其他一些非常有帮助的事情。首先是我们的“之前、期间和之后”方法。这是我们将事件前后的时间段分为三部分。所以“之前”部分可能是从你那天早上醒来一切正常开始，直到你注意到事情变得不同之前所做的所有事情。例如，在乔丹的案例中，他们那天起床、洗澡、吃早餐、送孩子上学，然后上车听广播并开车。
Perhaps you tune in to the memory of the songs or the stories that were being discussed and then even before the first thing that happened and that is the before section. The during section starts as soon as you begin to notice that something is not normal. So again with Jordan's example it might be suddenly seeing a stopped queue of traffic in front of them and they're needing to put your brakes on. So that is the during. The during section runs up until you're kind of out the other side really. So that might be when you get home again perhaps after being checked out by hospital or it might be when you get
也许你回想起当时播放的歌曲或讨论的故事，甚至在第一件事发生之前，这就是“之前”部分。 “期间”部分从你开始注意到事情不正常时开始。同样以乔丹的例子为例，这可能是突然看到前方有排队的车辆，需要踩刹车。所以这就是“期间”。 “期间”部分一直持续到你从另一边走出来。这可能是当你回到家，也许在医院检查之后，或者可能是当你被
dropped off by the car recovery firm for example, but it's when that kind of section of action is over. That's when the during section spans. I guess one interesting point about the during section is that sometimes when we're assessing people in clinic is that people really begin to make it clear in the way that they're talking about things or the way that they are describing what happened is that they still think it's happening now. They haven't got that sense of safety which has kind of triggered to them that it's not now that they're safe that this has passed. So that is an interesting one to look out for as well. The after section would be you know anything after. So anything from once that person is
汽车救援公司送回家时，但它是指那种行动部分结束的时候。这就是“期间”部分所跨越的时间。我想关于“期间”部分的一个有趣点是，有时我们在诊所评估人们时，人们在谈论事情的方式或描述发生的事情的方式中，清楚地表明他们仍然认为事情正在发生。他们没有那种安全感，即触发他们意识到“现在不是当时，他们是安全的，事情已经过去了”的感觉。所以这也是一个值得注意的有趣点。“之后”部分就是指任何之后的事情。所以从那个人
home again until right in this present day. And you can recount this in as much or little detail as you want. The theory behind this is that when something traumatic happens our brains don't always realize that it's not now. This has had a beginning section, a during section and an after section. So helping to really get that flow going can help the sequential processing and help make the body and the mind realize that this is over, this is not now. What happens before we do the before, the during and after is that you might struggle to get a coherent order. All of the different bits and pieces about the car crash for example, in Jordan's example might feel like you kind of go from A to D to B to Z to T to R to Q and doing this sequential before, during and after can really help the
再次回家直到现在的任何事情。你可以根据需要详细或简略地叙述。这背后的理论是，当创伤性事情发生时，我们的大脑并不总是意识到“现在不是当时”。这有一个开始部分、一个期间部分和一个之后部分。因此，帮助真正理清这个流程可以帮助顺序处理，并帮助身体和大脑意识到这已经结束了，现在不是当时。在我们做“之前、期间和之后”之前，你可能会难以理清一个连贯的顺序。所有关于车祸的零碎片段，在乔丹的例子中，可能感觉就像你从A到D到B到Z到T到R到Q，而做这个顺序性的“之前、期间和之后”真的可以帮助
body and the mind to process and assimilate and make sense of the order that this happened in. What can be also really nice, especially if you're working with a child, is to get them to draw their before, their during and their after. Try not to judge or criticize, just be open to conversations about what it is that the person has drawn and that's regardless of age. It's not just children that draw. Sometimes being able to tap into different ways of doing as well as the spoken word can really help the body and the mind to process all of
身体和大脑去处理、吸收并理清事情发生的顺序。特别是在与孩子一起工作时，让他们画出他们的“之前、期间和之后”也会非常棒。尽量不要评判或批评，只需对那个人画的内容保持开放的对话，这与年龄无关。不仅仅是孩子会画画。有时能够利用不同的表达方式，而不仅仅是口头语言，真的可以帮助身体和大脑处理所有
this. Similarly, you might find it helpful to write your experiences in terms of before, during and after too. If you're finding it very distressing to do this before, during and after section, it's okay to pop it away and come back to it when you feel stronger, or to go through it with somebody that you trust, or maybe even with a mental health professional too. When might be an indication that you or someone you care about might need to seek additional help? So signs that this might not be settling might be prolonged anxiety or worsening anxiety, nightmares, flashbacks, intrusive thoughts and hyper vigilance. It might be a sign that someone's functioning has been severely impacted on. All the things that
这些事情。同样，你可能会发现用“之前、期间和之后”来写下你的经历也很有帮助。如果你发现做这个“之前、期间和之后”部分非常痛苦，把它放一边，等你感觉更强壮时再回来处理，或者与你信任的人，甚至与心理健康专业人士一起完成也是可以的。什么时候可能预示着你或你关心的人需要寻求额外的帮助？所以，这些迹象可能表明情况没有好转，可能是长期的焦虑或焦虑加重、噩梦、闪回、侵入性思维和过度警觉。这可能是一个迹象，表明某人的功能受到了严重影响。所有
they would usually do such as dropping children at school, going to work, kind of doing all the different jobs in their family have stopped or changed in some way and that can be a real indication that all is not well. If this affects their work, their sleep, their relationships, this is an indication that additional help might be required. It's really important to reassure people that seeking help is not a sign of weakness.
他们通常会做的事情，比如送孩子上学、去上班、做家庭里的各种工作，都已经停止或以某种方式改变了，这可能是一个真正的迹象，表明一切都不太好。如果这影响了他们的工作、睡眠、人际关系，这就是需要额外帮助的迹象。向人们保证寻求帮助不是软弱的表现，这一点非常重要。
This is just the way our tricky human brains work and that it's entirely normal. Getting help as early as possible is likely to give you a really great chance of recovery. Technically speaking, we are allowed to respond to tricky, challenging, stressful events without this necessarily meaning this results in a post-traumatic stress disorder presentation. You have this with grief as well. It's only really after a couple of months of prolonged
这只是我们复杂的人类大脑的工作方式，这完全是正常的。尽早寻求帮助很可能会给你带来非常好的康复机会。从技术上讲，我们被允许对棘手、具有挑战性、压力大的事件做出反应，而不一定意味着这会导致创伤后应激障碍的表现。你在悲伤中也会有这种情况。只有在经历了几个月的长期
experiences of these signs and symptoms that we might begin to think this is cropping up outside of normal limits and that this is becoming complex complicated grief or PTSD. Basically if you're concerned about anyone about the risk to themselves or others, please do make contact with mental health services and or police services too if required. If this is something that's happened as a result of a crime, it's also important to get this reported and victim support might well be able to support you too. There are of course specific mental health treatments and approaches such as cognitive behavioral therapy, such as EMDR, such as compassion-focused therapy which really
这些迹象和症状后，我们才可能开始认为这超出了正常范围，并且这正在变成复杂的悲伤或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）。基本上，如果你担心任何人对自己或他人的风险，请务必联系心理健康服务机构，如果需要，也请联系警察部门。如果这是犯罪导致的后果，报告这一点也很重要，受害者支持机构很可能也能为你提供支持。当然，也有特定的心理健康治疗和方法，例如认知行为疗法、EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）、以同情为中心的疗法，这些真的
can make a very big difference for how people are feeling and getting this traumatic event to lay flat and to be better assimilated into their life. So last but not least, trauma reactions are all part of being human. Often when I've been through the tricky brain kit exercise with people, they absolutely then understand the theory, but do wish perhaps there are real benefits to being human, one of which being that you can get £10 off the price of a tricky brain kit by using the code YouTube10 at checkout. Hope is so important. Recovery is possible. Help is available. If you have been through something traumatic or challenging or someone you care about has, this can feel really derailing and so my heart goes out to you. Please do look after yourselves. Please do try and rest.
可以对人们的感受产生很大的影响，并使这个创伤性事件平复下来，更好地融入他们的生活。最后但同样重要的是，创伤反应是人性的一部分。通常当我与人们一起完成“棘手大脑工具包”练习时，他们完全理解了理论，但确实希望人类有一些真正的好处，其中之一就是你可以在结账时使用代码YouTube10，以10英镑的价格购买棘手大脑工具包。希望非常重要。康复是可能的。帮助是可用的。如果你经历过创伤性或挑战性的事情，或者你关心的人经历过，这可能会让人感到非常崩溃，所以我的心与你同在。请务必照顾好自己。请务必尝试休息。
Please do try to talk about your experiences. I would love it if you found this helpful, if you would like it, if you would drop me a comment, if you would share with others too. Perhaps if you've been through something traumatic and come out the other side, it might be really helpful and empowering if you were able to drop a comment on YouTube to let others know that this is possible. Thank you so much for watching or listening to this episode. I will be along with the next episode from 10am on Saturdays on YouTube and wherever you get your podcast from 6am on Mondays. Please do take care of yourself and I'll see you very soon. Let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
请务必尝试谈论你的经历。如果你觉得这有帮助，如果你喜欢它，如果你能给我留个言，如果你能与他人分享，我会很高兴。也许如果你经历过创伤并走出了阴影，如果你能在YouTube上留言让其他人知道这是可能的，那可能会非常有帮助和赋能。非常感谢你观看或收听这一集。我将在周六上午10点在YouTube上发布下一集，并在周一上午6点在你获取播客的地方发布。请务必照顾好自己，我们很快再见。让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路，这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》
With Dr. Marianne Trent There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。